what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with the 10 lives of wolverine
and kind of the funny thing about this
uh when i did the 10 deaths of wolverine
i thought you guys were gonna hate it
and you guys were like no we want to see
where the story goes and i was like okay
i
guess admittedly i'm a little curious
myself i was gonna keep on reading it it
was just a matter of whether or not you
guys wanted to see me covered or not but
uh yeah we can do that so for those of
you guys who are just joining us keep in
mind that one of the things that's going
on here is marvel's alternating the
stories so the 10 lives of wolverine
basically deals with wolverine's mind
from his present day being guided by
jean grey from the present day his mind
being sent into the past of basically
different points in his history in order
to stop the assassination of charles
xavier with the 10 deaths of wolverine's
story we don't know what the hell is
going on we just know like things are
happening and it just seems to focus on
more and mick hager maybe it'll all come
together by the end of the story i have
no clue so the way this works is that
initially you pick up with what with a
really really interesting situation here
that you basically have wolverine as a
teenager living out there in the
canadian wilderness which i think is the
northwest territories honestly i'm not
very knowledgeable when it comes to like
canadian geography basically like way up
there in the northern territories as i
understand it there are people who live
up there it's a precious few number of
people because it's just such a harsh
environment and it's so difficult to
live there but as i understand it people
live there and during wolverine's time
one of the things to know is that
following the the introduction of his
powers right the use of his abilities
that he essentially took off right ended
up out in the the northwest territories
of canada and stayed there for a while
for a while he was actually living out
the woods by himself but nonetheless it
was one of those things where he was
living like a wolf essentially where his
kind of animal instincts we're honed and
that's one of the reasons why they're so
refined in the modern day uh but at this
point in time he's just kind of out
there in northern canada basically just
fighting a polar bear and the sort of
gladiatorial games kind of thing it more
or less seems to be one of the ways in
which he earns his keep around here but
one of the things that happens is that
in the middle of this fight suddenly the
transition takes place now this is where
things are interesting because in the
first 10 lives of wolverine video that
we did the first story we basically
picked up with wolverine when his mind
was sent into the past of his younger
self in order to basically save the life
of charles xavier when xavier was being
born and so just based on that the
assumption that i had is that all the
stories would basically go forward
covering these kind of hallmark moments
of wolverine's life and the fact that he
would have to kind of deviate from what
he was supposed to be doing at the time
in order to save charles xavier at that
point in time what it looks like is
going on here is that the attempted
assassinations of charles xavier
actually go back much earlier than that
and in fact it's really the attempt to
destroy the xavier family line and so
that x that you see on his head kind of
like the energy x that's basically the
mind of wolverine from the present day
taking over the body of his younger self
and that of course he's also guided by
it by jean grey and that's why he just
kind of bails out just takes off and
runs uh because it's like okay like jean
grey's guiding him it's basically his
present-day mind that's like okay we got
a job to do you know and then going
forward and trying to find a way to save
charles xavier now at that point you
actually switch over to jasmine falls
japan and that's one of the things a
little murky about this is that you kind
of get this bit of bouncing around along
the history of wolverine's timeline so
this isn't really in any particular
order i mean it kind of is insofar as
like their progression but nonetheless
one of the things that happens here is
that he is basically there with itsu now
itsu was like the love interest of
wolverine right like the woman he loved
before he met jean i mean he's had a lot
of women over the course of his life but
it's the only one he was ever really and
truly in love with the other part of
this is that izo is the mother of deacon
right the son of wolverine and so with
this whole thing kind of going on here
what's sort of interesting is jean grey
is watching all this because she's a
creep and he's like just give me another
minute right you know and it's kind of
like you know like we have we have all
night girl like you know him and eats
you now of course once he is in what is
really this vulnerable state suddenly
you realize she's possessed by the
spirit of omega red right by the the
essence of omega red really like omega
red's mind and so because of that it is
one of those things where like she's
about to go on the attack now what you
end up doing is switching away from that
we'll circle back around to that as we
get towards the end of this video but
you switch away from that and then you
basically pick up in colombia with
wolverine as part of team x and now this
is when we start to get into a bit of
history involving wolverine specifically
team x and the reason why i think we
need to cover that if for no other
reason than the fact that it's just cool
so here's the thing so team x was
initially a joint venture between the
weapons plus program and the united
states cia of course weapons plus was
basically the attempt to create super
soldiers which included captain america
as weapon one albeit without his
knowledge of course that was established
in grant morrison's new x-men and then
basically all the iterations after uh
captain america following his presumed
death going all the way up to weapon x
which was weapon 10. now initially when
you had like wolverine and maverick and
sabertooth and these guys who were all
all part of team x they were not
initially part of the weapon x program
yet that wouldn't come until about a
decade after the team disbanded instead
they were just one of many groups that
existed out there that were black ops
wet work teams furthering the agenda of
the cia and in doing so establishing the
validity of the weapons plus program
insofar as creating what are in effect
super soldiers but without having to do
anything particularly special to them i
mean don't get me wrong at this point in
time weapons plus is still making
weapons programs right so like i i
believe and i'm not going to swear to
that because marvel doesn't really give
us like a definitive timeline but i
believe at this point in time when team
x is off doing their thing weapons plus
is working on weapons seven eight and
nine i think is what they're doing and
then eventually professor thornton and
and carol hines and abraham cornelius
will turn their sights to wolverine and
maverick and sabertooth and silver fox
and basically bring them in as the 10th
iteration of the weapons plus program
also known as weapon x so at this point
in time wolverine does not have
adamantium bonded to his skeleton is
basically what i'm saying here now one
of the things to know is that this is
one of wolverine's darker
at least the darker aspects of his
history we'll talk about that here in a
little bit but this is one of those
points where the mind of his present-day
self basically takes over the mind of
himself here as part of team x and being
guided by jean grey it's we have to go
find charles xavier he's basically over
that way now the funny thing about this
is that the indication here is that had
there not been some kind of a
circumstance where somebody was out
there trying to take out charles xavier
that none of this would be necessary and
that's what's kind of interesting is
because while technically giant size
x-men number one was the first time that
wolverine met professor x their paths
crossed incredibly closely like here in
colombia professor x was like 50 yards
or or 50 clicks you know in that
direction basically he wasn't that far
off right he was you know within like
maybe a couple hours distance of
wolverine their paths crossed relatively
consistently but this is where he's kind
of like okay i don't know if i can do
this and the reason why is because when
he when he tells gene gray he basically
says that like over the course of his
life especially when he was part of team
x i mean they did all kinds of things
but here in this place in particularly
they ended up like mowing down hundreds
of villagers right they had mass graves
they had burn piles and it was all team
x right like they they killed everybody
here right it was just it was a an
enormous massacre and wolverine hated
the fact that he had done that and the
reason why is that while he was not
officially part of weapon x and hadn't
necessarily had adamantium bonded to his
skeleton or anything like that he was
having his memories wiped alongside
sabertooth and and maverick it wasn't
something they were doing willingly but
like his mind was being wiped he was
being given false truths different
things along those lines and so it's one
of those where he was like i can do this
but if i do i cannot allow this darker
part of my history to continue but i
cannot allow this just giant massacre to
take place and so what he ends up doing
is actually going back to where uh where
like maverick and sabertooth and all
those guys are and then he basically
attacks him right just like masochism
now he doesn't necessarily kill them per
se but he injures the hell out of it
right so much so that they can't really
even complete their mission and so as
wolverine leaves you actually end up
seeing sabertooth contacting the
professor and saying like like a like
wolverine has basically gone awol right
so uh so when he's asked the question
like do you require extraction whose
response is no i'm just telling you i'm
gonna kill wolverine now here's
something that i want to establish here
this is not professor xavier that he's
talking to this is professor thornton
the leader of weapon uh weapons plus i
feel it felt like that was something
that needed to be said because i feel
like that would throw a lot of people
off like why is sabertooth there is he
working with professor x that's not
what's going on right he's talking to
professor thor right as the the leader
of weapons plus and so from there like
wolverine basically intends to kind of
go forward with his mission and this is
where things get particularly
interesting here because at that point
you basically jump back to a point
whereby wolverine and uh and domino and
basically uh omega red operating is what
is in effect x-force as part of the
whole curcumin uh campaign and
everything where basically they're
tracking down a guy by the name of maxim
ivanov who was essentially the head of
the russian hellfire club as he calls it
and then he basically took over a kind
of a bathhouse for himself the intention
is to grab him extract him and
interrogate him in krakowa to find out
basically how far reaching the the
russian hellfire club is as well as what
impact it's having unlike the mutant
population because they've literally
made life hell for like domino and
seemingly anybody else as part of
x-force who stumbled across their path
once this happens here's the reason why
this matters once this happens and
basically omega red runs and enters the
bathhouse he's actually met by mikhail
rasputin now the reason why we're
getting this here is because we didn't
fully know why it is that omega red is
the one who's basically hunting down
professor xavier through the timeline
and trying to kill him or at least
destroy his family line this seems to be
the reason why but even then we're not a
hundred percent sure when mikhail
rasputin shows up right remember mikhail
rasputin is a guy who has the ability to
alter matter on a localized space he's
one step away right he's one rider away
from being a guy who can alter reality
on a universal scale right because one
thing to keep in mind when it comes to
altering matter some people can do it on
a local level right iceman is a good
example of that and then there are
people who can do it on a universal
level franklin richards is an example of
that all it takes is one writer and that
character getting just a power boost
suddenly you can alter reality because
being able to alter the movement of
matter is only one step away from being
able to just separate molecules and then
recombine those atoms into new molecules
right this is literally just one step
away and so it's one of those things
where mikhail rasputin is one of my
favorite characters of all time one
because of just the story arcs he's been
in which have been amazing and two
because of his potential he could just
be ridiculously op one day but what he
does here is he actually just kind of uh
alters the body of of omega red
momentarily and then deactivates the
tracking device on the carbonation
synthesizer that was given to him by the
uh by the the quiet council in krakowa
when they resurrected him right remember
the promise they made is if you do what
you're supposed to do we will resurrect
you and we will give you a carbonation
synthesizer to essentially stabilize
your body what he didn't know and what
he later found out is that they had
basically done this with a tracking
device they were treating him like some
kind of an animal right like a dog that
they were keeping on a leash mikhail
rasputin is deactivating that and one of
the reasons why is he says at some
future point in time you will come back
to me right at some point in time you
will come to me and you will seek my aid
as repayment for what i've done for you
here but also because you will have a
vendetta and so this seemingly is or at
least kind of gives us this early
indication of why omega red is basically
trying to kill charles xavier but again
what we end up doing is jumping back to
1900 right teenage wolf reign as he's
being guided by uh by uh jean grey and
what you actually have here is a guy
named captain xavier seemingly back in
the year 1900 the beginnings of the
xavier family line or maybe as far back
as they're willing to go we might even
find the sabertooth is going back
further we might find that in future
stories but basically what ends up
happening is essentially hollingsworth
tries to attack him of course being
possessed by uh by by omega red and then
in turn once hollingsworth is like
thrown overboard or really just kind of
ends up lunging himself overboard that
everybody else is possessed by omega red
and then then literally captain xavier
is like okay so it's mutiny then is
what's going on here and it's one of
those things where what omega red really
seems to do is basically feed on the
anger and the disdain of the people
around him and and the reason why is
because these guys have basically been
stuck in ice for quite some time and
that while they had basically managed to
catch some seals and whatnot being stuck
in the ice in the darkness in northern
canada basically pissed them off and
essentially what it looks like is omega
red is building on that right omega red
is using that hatred and that anger now
from there we actually end up finding
out wolverine is heading directly
towards captain xavier so presumably of
course it looks like he'll end up saving
his life we don't find out here instead
what we end up doing is switching over
to the fight between itsu and wolverine
when isu possessed by omega red goes in
for the attack and it's one of those
things where wolverine is doing
everything he can to basically
neutralize her without having to kill
her but knowing omega red as he knows
him and knowing how capable itsu is as a
fighter wolverine seemingly realizes the
only way to stop this is to kill itsu
and so what it looks like marvel's doing
here is unlike the origin of daycan and
like the death of itsu as it was
originally told which was that itsu was
killed by seemingly saber tooth i think
that instead it actually ends up being
wolverine who has to kill her and
wolverine is the one who's responsible
for the death of dakin's mom and so it's
it's that's this is why i say i feel
like marvel's gonna be going through and
changing the history of wolverine
changing his origin up right just kind
of switching things around i don't know
if that's gonna be the case or not but
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments section either way thank
you guys for watching this video and i
will catch you all later
peace